obviously if we're gonna go down this
route i would say my tastes are a bit
superior of course i know my way around
not as a [ __ ] but as like a
take what okay no being really
convincing
but like so i would say like i honestly
prefer
if i'm going to be reading hentai or
like
hentai dojins or hentai manga like so
i guess what's your go-to tag
penetration
oh definitely able penetration it
depends on the day
sometimes i'm looking for like virginity
sometimes i'm feeling just to be pure
you know like something
you're like awesome like i'm to give
myself and then sometimes i'm just
like what's the most skull [ __ ]
[ __ ] skull i want to see those jizz
i want a position of power being abused
through the eye socket yeah do you have
any like specific titles that you would
recommend
obviously anything by pochi which is uh
uh hentai manga artist and she's also
having an
anime being released it was delayed yeah
it was supposed to come out
last season yeah absolutely um she
obviously at the
anime getting you know animated for
she's the artist who did the
art for the milf isekai if i remember
exactly
yeah and the uh elder sister dojinshi
oh okay but it's not going to be the
hentai version of that it's going to be
the one yeah
like the tan girl no no that's now
you're talking about nanashi
who did uh nagato
if i'm completely honest i always like
to go to
series that are like of characters that
are like in the games i'm playing like i
like playing like harvest moon and rune
factory and sometimes i like
to see the characters like to marry have
sex with my character
well i guess that's just like the i
guess that's just like the appeal of the
ginsengs right
i've never played a video game and
thought man [ __ ] i just want to see
zefroff just take a hug
you look that [ __ ] up there's probably
thousands i don't know because they're
probably getting
do you guys remember the very first
dojinshi that you ever read or like
never
discovered you've never read a digital
okay connor's told me that he can't get
off to drawn paul no
what it's like a [ __ ] just i i i have
more chance like [ __ ] masturbating to
like
uh money like the queen
it's doing the same thing for me like
you know what i mean like i need some
[ __ ] movement going on
so do you need is it the movement is it
the noise literally masturbating the
same way they did in like 1800s when the
camera was functioning
like oh god my my wife that i haven't
seen in 40 years because i went to the
war
i'm gonna bust away but you should never
like did you never like look at like
the [ __ ] playboy magazines and think
like damn that's hot yeah i did but then
i realized like
moving porn was also an option and then
like how can you go back
it's like it's like the episode of south
park where like they they lose internet
and then they take turns on like the pc
masturbating to pawn
i guess i guess
i guess it's because for me like i
remember the very first time i
discovered the jinxies were a thing
where yeah you know you you'd watch the
you you'd watch these anime
and you'd be like you know this this
this anime goes like kind of hot
but of course because it's an officially
licensed product you don't get to see
any porn of that i've never felt that
way about anime i've never seen anime
being like man i want to see these
characters get [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
really no no no even not even as like a
kid but have you never had like a
childhood crush
on like a girl but i've never like
wanted to like
because to me it feels like i don't know
this is weird but like
i i like it when my like porn is
separated from the stuff i enjoy
you know what i mean no i can't i want
it completely isolated i get that okay
so i can cut that [ __ ] off and nothing
in my life changes right like what's
that like no nut challenge we start
levitating after
yeah like if i want to cut that [ __ ] out
it's not going to affect like
you know if i'm looking at me casa porn
every week and then i'm going to be
watching attack on titan i'm going to be
like damn
i've seen her get digged down like i
no i get that though because like i
don't read doujins of
series that i like right because you
want to only read really i read dozens
of series i actually don't like
but like the characters are hot and you
don't like them like yeah because like i
don't because i don't care because i get
that the characters are good looking but
i don't care enough about their
personality
to see them get [ __ ] out yeah i would
never want to read you know what i mean
from a show that i i like enjoy i don't
know
so like my favorite i'm i'm am i the am
i the weird one here no no no there's a
lot of people who are like i love this
character
therefore i want to see them get
dictated but i don't follow it
okay all right i'm going to watch
because that's why like that's why like
i [ __ ] love like sword online or emo
like love life
because i don't care about these
characters enough but they're all
good-looking characters
that's cool when you like watch a porno
i don't want to be personally invested
in their lives i'm watching a porno i
like watching
no i want like being personally involved
this is going to sound
this is going to sound so [ __ ] intel
right now
being invested in porn just like
elevates it to like
like newer heights that's that's why i
like porn
that's like that's why i like plot with
my porn but at the end of the day i feel
like you're putting up more barriers
for like entry to have a good just wank
at the end
you know what i mean but that wig is
worth it though
it's like the best one you're gonna get
you feel the shivers
oh my god no because i get i if i watch
a dog you know i read a dozen of a
character that i really like or series i
really like
the next time i have anything to do with
that seriously in the back of my mind
i'm just like yeah i'm thinking about it
and it completely puts me out of the
experience oh what
and how also is that like why do you
want to put
work on yourself by reading and having
to imagine the rest you know what i mean
because
because i have to imagine the rest it's
drawn out it's not every single like
little frame in your mind
that just means you've read [ __ ] yeah i
know i've never read
i don't know like it's like it's that's
like saying is is all sex the same to
you you know what i'm being like is is
every session of sex
like exactly the same but that's that's
exactly the same with like porn and
stuff like that right well okay why do
you okay this could get way too deep
what the same the same reason why anyone
does the after the time
right i am 90 of the time i just do it
because i got nothing better going on
i'll be honest with you i got like 10
minutes to kill i don't want to do the
tasks that i've set myself like i've got
to make this thumbnail i don't want to
do it
well i guess um so you just do it to
waste time yeah
most people you know walk or clean
yeah whatever i got five minutes i've
got five minutes free when i want to
have a quick like uh danger whack or
whatever it's free right now
but i like it's you know like most
people the the act of doing it is a
physically pleasurable for me i just
feel like it's right it cleans my mind
i don't know i feel like it's like a
reset i'm like a save it's like you've
gone to the pokemon
you're talking like a [ __ ] monk now
for some reason
you're like i feel i feel clean
you go in your bedroom you know if it's
midday you feel dirty that you're gonna
like do it and then you're like all
right and then you do it then you come
out like levitating like
it's like hard resetting a call i'm
ready for a day yeah yeah
it's like i couldn't just like reset the
game like in the game or i could turn
off
the console back on you've got like 20
chrome tabs open the shit's
really slow you're like [ __ ] i'll
just restart the pc like that's what
it's like
yeah i mean you just close the tabs
sometimes it's still not so laggy you
know and just like [ __ ] restart it